undoubtedly one of the modern history's
most notorious and abhorrent killers his
crimes they're the stuff of nightmares
over the course of 13 years he prowled
four men and lured them back to his
house before drugging them and
strangling them in all he took the lives
of 17 men between 1978 and 1991 but
simply killing his victims wasn't enough
for Jeffrey Dahmer he never wanted them
to leave so he saved several trophies
including severed heads eventually even
eight parts of the victims Dahmer was
captured in 1991 and sentenced to 16
life terms he was killed by fellow
prison inmate Christopher's Carver in
1994 and in today's video we're taking a
look at this serial killers dark life
[Music]
Jeffrey Dahmer was born on May the 21st
1960 in Milwaukee Wisconsin to Lionel
and Joyce Dharma he was described by his
mother as a beautiful baby and both
parents considered him to be the normal
child but his teachers they saw him
differently at least one his first-grade
teacher wondered if Jeffrey was
neglected at home and noted that he was
a reserved child on his report cart in
truth both of Jeffrey's parents didn't
spend a lot of time with him when
Jeffrey was young his father was in
college earning a chemistry degree and
Jeffrey's mother was often bedridden
recovering from illnesses Jeffrey's
parents had a tumultuous marriage that
he later described as extreme tension
from the constant arguing Italian yet
there was no doubt Lionel and Royce
Donna loved their son and tried do the
best for him when he was six years old
worried Jeffery might not take well to a
new baby brother
they let him pick out his name Jeffrey
named his younger brother David the
Dharma family moved a few times before
eventually settling in bath in Ohio in
1968 if there were any red flags that
indicated future violence in the young
Jeffrey it was his fascination with
animal bones and how they fit together
the interest in carcasses began when he
was four years old
one day Jeffrey was helping his father
clear animal remains from under the
house and Jeffrey was oddly thrilled by
the sound of the bones dropping into the
metal bucket he later began collecting
them searching in ditches and along
streets for roadkill
he began dismembering the bodies behind
the house in a patch of wooded area and
stored the various body parts in jars in
the family's woodshed on one occasion
Jeffrey decapitated the corpse of a dog
before nailing the body to a tree when
he was 10 years old over dinner Jeffrey
asked his father what would happen if
chicken bones were placed in beach
Lionel a chemist interpreted his son's
question as mere scientific curiosity
and he took the opportunity to teach his
son about the proper way to clean and
preserve his collections Jeffrey later
admitted at the age of 14 that he began
experiencing sexual compulsions he
desired boys not girls and these sexual
fantasies involved submission violence
and death he began drinking as a
teenager to suppress his urges and
didn't talk to anyone about the
disturbing thought
that he was having at the age of 16 he
fantasized about raping a jogger he saw
regularly and planned to attack the man
one day Jeffrey layin weight with a
baseball bat in the bushes along the
man's regular route the man didn't come
by that day and Jeffrey never attempted
to carry it out again a Revere high
school most of his classmates thought of
Dharma as an outcast with few friends
some were troubled by his heavy drinking
he drunk both beer and liquor at school
smuggling it's inside the lining of his
army fatigue jacket his grades weren't
average and then took a dive as his
drinking spun out of control in 1977 he
played clarinet briefly in abandoned was
a decent tennis player overall his
teachers observed Jeffrey is a polite
and quiet boy although he was awkward he
regularly amused his classmates by
staging pranks such as acting out
seizures knocking over items and making
loud and obnoxious noises the pranks
were so popular that similar behavior
was referred to as doing a dharma by the
end of high school
damas parents troubled marriage finally
came to an end after an unsuccessful
attempt at counseling in early 1978
Lionel moved out of the house Donna
graduated in May of that same year a few
weeks after graduation Donna committed
his first murder when he picked up a
hitchhiker
eighteen-year-old Steven Mark Hicks was
on his way to a rock concert when Donna
lured him back to his house to hang out
and drink a few beers before the show by
now Dahmer lived alone at his parents's
house his mother moved out with younger
brother David while his father took up
residence at a local motel Hicks and
Dahmer spent a few hours together
listening to music and drinking when
Hicks was ready to leave Dahmer
didn't want him to so he struck him in
the head with a ten pound dumbbell and
strangled him to death while Hicks was
unconscious he then proceeded to
masturbate over his body moved him to
the crawlspace under the house and
dissected his body before burying it in
a shallow grave several weeks later
Dahmer unearthed ticks his body had the
flesh from the bones and dissolved it in
acid he crushed Hicks's bones with a
sledgehammer and sprinkled them in the
woodlot behind the house a short time
later Dharma's father visited his son
and learned that he was living alone he
moved back into the house and convinced
Donna to enroll in college Dharma spent
three months at Ohio State University
before dropping out in early of 1979 at
the urging of his father he joined the
US Army Donna served as a combat medic
Germany but his performance deteriorated
due to his drinking he was honorably
discharged in March of 1981 at least two
soldiers later attested that dama rapes
them while in the service one thing has
happened repeatedly over the course of
17 months and the other claims that
Dharma drugged him
[Music]
following his discharge Dhamma returned
home to a hire that stayed only a brief
time he was arrested for disorderly
conduct which prompted his father to
arrange for Dharma to live with his
grandmother in Wisconsin his alcoholism
continued and he was arrested for
indecent exposure
he was arrested again in 1986 when two
boys accused him of masturbating in
front of them in September of 1987
Dharma took his second victim
this man was Steven too Amy according to
Dharma he has no memory of killing two
Amy they have checked into a hotel room
together and drank heavily and Dom awoke
in the morning and discovered the body
next to him Dharma bought a large
suitcase to transport to Amy's remains
to his grandmother's basement where he
dismembered and masturbated over the
corpse support disposing of their
remains only after Dharma killed another
two victims at his grandmother's home
did she tire of his late nights and his
drunkenness she had no knowledge of his
other activities and forced him to move
out of the premises in 1988 that
September of 1988 dama had an extremely
lucky escape an encounter with a 13 year
old lowchen boy resulted in charges of
sexual exploitation and second degree
sexual assault for Dahmer he pled guilty
claiming that the boy had appeared much
older while awaiting sentencing for the
sexual assault case
Dahmer again put his grandmother's
basement to a gruesome use in March of
1989 he lured drugged strangled
sodomized photographed dismembered and
disposed of Anthony Sears an aspiring
model at his trial for child molestation
in 1989 donna was the model of
contrition he argued eloquently in his
own defense about how he had seen the
error of his ways and that his arrest
marked a turning point in his life his
defense counsel argued that he needed
treatment not incarceration and the
judge agreed handing down a one-year
prison sentence on day release allowing
Dharma to work his job during the day
and return to prison at night as well as
handing down a five-year probationary
sentence years later in an interview
with CNN Lionel Dahmer stated that he
wrote a letter to the court that issued
that sentence requesting psychological
help before his son's parole however
Jeffrey Dahmer was granted an early
release by the judge after serving only
ten months of a sentence he briefly
lived with his grandmother following his
release during which time he does not
have appear too added to his body count
before moving back
to his own apartment over the following
years Dharma's victim counts accelerated
bringing his total from four to 17 he
developed rituals as he progressed
experimenting with chemical means of
disposal and often consuming the flesh
of his victims dharma are also attempted
crude lobotomy is drilling into victims
skulls while they were still alive and
injecting them with muriatic acid he was
careful to select victims on the fringes
of society who were often itinerant or
borderline criminal making their
disappearances less noticeable and
reducing the likelihood of his capture
as the murders piled up Dahmer was still
unsatisfied he stated later I was
completely swept along with my own
compulsion I don't know how else to put
it it didn't satisfy me completely so
maybe I was thinking maybe another one
well maybe this one will and the numbers
started growing and growing and just got
out of control as you can see on May the
27th 1991 Dharma's neighbor Sandra Smith
called the police to report that an
Asian boy was running naked in the
street when the police arrived the boy
was incoherent and they accepted the
word of Dharma a white man living in a
largely poor african-american community
that the boy was his 19 year old lover
in fact the boy was 14 years old and he
was the brother of the 14 year old teen
that Dahmer had previously molested the
police escorted Dahmer and the boy home
and clearly not wishing to become
embroiled in a homosexual domestic
disturbance took only a cursory look
around before leaving once the police
left the scene Donna killed the boy and
proceeded his usual rituals they
conducted even a basic search police
officers would have found the body of
dharmas 12th victim Tony Hughes before
he was finally arrested on July the 22nd
1991 he killed four more men
[Music]
damas killing spree ended when he was
arrested on July the 22nd 1991 that day
to Milwaukee police officers picked up
Tracy Edwards a 32 year old
african-american man who was wandering
the streets with a handcuff dangling
from his wrist they decided to
investigate the man's claims that a
weird dude had drugged and restrained
him they arrived at Dharma's apartment
where he calmly offered to get the keys
for the handcuffs
Edwards claimed that the knife Dahmer
had threatened him with was in the
bedroom and the officer went in to
corroborate the story he noticed
Polaroid photographs of dismembered
bodies lying around it was at that point
that Dahmer was subdued by the officers
subsequent searches revealed a head in
the refrigerator three more in the
freezer and a catalog of other Horrors
including preserved skulls jars
containing genitalia and an extensive
gallery of macabre Polaroid photographs
of his victims Dharma's refrigerator and
Polaroid photographs became inextricably
associated with his notorious killing
spree in 1996 following Dharma's death a
group of Milwaukee businessman raised
more than $400,000 to purchase the items
that he used for his victims including
blades saws handcuffs and a refrigerator
to store the body parts they promptly
destroyed them in an effort to distance
the city from the horrors of Damas
actions and the ensuing media circus
that surrounded his trial
[Music]
Jeffrey Dahmer's trial began in January
of 1992 given that the majority of
dharmas victims were african-american
there were considerable racial tensions
and so strict security precautions were
taken including an 8-foot barrier of
bulletproof glass that separated him
from the gallery the inclusion of only
one african-american on the jury
provoked further unrest but was
ultimately contains and very short-lived
wine or Donna and his second wife
attended the trial throughout Dahmer
initially pled not guilty to all charges
despite having confessed to the killings
during police interrogation but he
eventually changed his plea to guilty by
virtue of insanity his defense then
offered the gruesome details of his
behavior as proof that only someone
truly insane
would commit such terrible acts Donna
later said in an interview it's hard for
me to believe that a human being could
have done what I've done but I know that
I did it the jury chose to believe the
prosecution's assertions that Dahmer was
fully aware that his acts were evil and
that he chose to commit them anyway on
February the 15th 1992 they returned
after approximately 10 hours
deliberation to find him guilty but sane
on all counts he was sentenced to 15
consecutive life terms in prison with a
sixteenth term tacked on in May it is
now over this has never been the case of
trying to get free I didn't ever want
freedom this was a case to tell the
world that I did what I did but not for
reasons of hate I hated no one I knew I
was sick or evil or both now I believe I
was sick the doctors have told me about
my sickness and now I have some peace I
know how much Holocaust I thank God
there will be no more harm that I can do
I believe that only the Lord Jesus
Christ can save me from my sins I ask
for no consideration Dharma reportedly
adjusted well to prison life although he
was initially kept apart from the
general population
he eventually convinced the authorities
to allow him to integrate more fully
with the other inmates he found religion
in the form of books and photos sent to
him by his father and he was granted
permission by the Columbia Correctional
Institution to be baptized by a local
Pass
[Music]
on November the 28th 1994 in accordance
with its inclusion in regular work
details Dharma was assigned to work with
two other convicted murderers Jessie
Anderson and Christopher Scavo
after they had been left alone to
complete their tasks guards returned to
find that Scavo had brutally beaten both
men with a metal bar from the prison
weight room Dharma it was pronounced
dead after approximately an hour
Anderson succumbed to his injuries days
later in 2015 Christopher's Garver spoke
to the New York Post about his reasons
for killing Donna Scavo alleged that he
was disturbed not only by Dharma's
crimes but by a habit Dharma had
developed of fashioning severed limbs
from prison food to antagonize other
inmates after being taunted by Dharma
and Anderson during their work detail
Scavo said that he confronted Dharma
about his crimes before beating the two
men to death he also claims that the
prison guards allowed the murder to
happen in Damas well he requested that
upon his death his body be cremated as
soon as possible that some medical
researchers wanted his brain preserved
so that it can be studied Lionel Dahmer
wanted to respect his son's wishes and
cremate all remains his mother felt his
brain should go to research the two
parents went to court and a judge sided
with Lionel after one year Dharma's body
was released and the remains were
cremated as he requested in August of
2012 nearly two decades after his death
it was reported that his childhood home
in Bath ajillo
where he committed his first murder in
1978 and buried his victims remains was
on the market its owner musician Chris
Butler stated that the property would
make a great home as long as the buyer
could get past the horror factor in
March of 2016
Butler put the house up for rent for
$8,000 for the week of the Republican
National Convention as of July 2017 the
house was no longer listed on the market
according to Zillow so I really hope you
enjoyed that episode of biographic if
you did there's a couple of things you
could do right now one is hit that like
button below also if you want more stuff
like this we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday so hit
that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday when we put out a
new video also if you want to watch
something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]